[Music]
our next question today is from jamie
my wife and i were driving down the road
and on the side of the road there's this
beautiful jeep wrangler for sale talking
with my wife hey that'd be fun we should
get it why not and
within two minutes of passing it i had
in my head bought it got it home and
then i just looked over at her and i go
what just happened if we had not seen
that we wouldn't be discussing this it
wouldn't even been on our minds but it
just popped up and it made me think if i
didn't see it we'd be fine and i started
to think a little more about this going
okay if it was blind i wouldn't have
seen this i wouldn't see
any of these things that i think i want
i wouldn't see
myself in the morning
aging i wouldn't see the gray hair i
wouldn't see
these things and have some discontent
with it and uh i just
i don't know it was just something
interesting i had thought about and are
blind people minimalist do they worry
about shelter and food and love and
music and taste and
did they not get caught up in
the things that we get caught up with
because we can see things
that we don't need
wow yeah what does the bible say tk
if your eyes fault you carve them out
[Laughter]
doesn't it seriously say something like
that i was at a meditation class last
night and
it was an hour and a half nature
meditation
and
it really appealed to all of the senses
throughout even taste like he would hand
you a raspberry and you had like five
minutes to experience how
bitter it was and how sweet it was and
the textures and
what i realized when you slow down
stillness is almost a a misnomer because
everything is moving we're just moving
so much faster
than everything that we think of is
still but we were doing this walking
meditation outside
and the
invitation was to see
what's in motion
it turns out that virtually everything
is in motion everything that seems still
the trees are just swaying slightly the
light is bending on the roof making it
appear as though it's moving subtly and
so yes if i was blind i wouldn't have
seen any of those things but throughout
the meditation we often are invited to
close our eyes and what does that do it
just amps up the other senses and so a
minimalist is someone who is deliberate
about their consumption but we don't
consume only visually
in the world that we live in we are
often primarily
visual creatures especially as jaime is
driving with his wife and they see this
jeep they want to buy sure you may have
not had that impulse
but we have this segment on the podcast
about impulse purchases on the private
podcast where we talk about our impulses
and what they do to us and ultimately
our impulses
blind us
to the truth
and so
if you're a blind person it doesn't mean
that you wouldn't have impulses they
would just manifest differently that's
right yeah that's right
yeah integrity isn't defined by the
absence or presence of good and bad
impulses it's determined by how you
choose to process them
how you choose to react and respond to
them and no matter what you have going
on in terms of your abilities
as a human being you will feel
contradictory impulses
and in that moment you will have to make
a choice well i let my impulses rule
over me or will i come to attention will
i choose to be mindful will i choose to
process in a way that creates the space
to make a healthy decision and i think
jamie you might not be giving yourself
enough credit when you tell this story
because it's not about you seeing the
jeep versus you not seeing the jeep
because even if you couldn't see there
would be some other impulse that would
arise that could tempt you to do
something that's unhealthy what i love
the most about your story is that you
gave yourself the two minutes
you gave yourself the pause you gave
yourself the opportunity to question
your decision and to ask yourself is
this what i really want and i think
that's a reflection of your inner work
and i think that's a lesson for us all
that the thing that saves us is the time
and energy we put into doing that kind
of inner work so when not if we
experience impulses to do things that
are unhealthy there is a pause there is
the opportunity to process amen yeah
man you know i think
i think this has
less to do with sight
and it has more to do with comparison
because that's what's happening is like
when any time jamie sees the gray hair
any time he sees the car or anytime you
see it's not the fact that he's seeing
it i mean that that can
initiate this
um this comparison thing that he that
jamie has going on um but yeah i mean
that's
that's really what i would look at jamie
it's not about
whether or not you can see it's when you
are seeing
are you using that as an opportunity to
appreciate something or to compare
yourself to something because uh what do
they say comparison is a killer of joy
yes and um
yeah i
i think that even if you didn't have
your sight still find other ways to
compare yourself
to um
because it's not even to others it's
like he when he looks in the mirror he's
con he's comparing his current self to a
better version of himself well and
that's the problem betterment is an
illusion exactly yeah we don't try to
improve a baby but at some point once
you're 13 years old 18 years old 25
years old 40 years old how can i improve
how can i improve my health how can i
improve myself how can i improve my skin
care routine as opposed to the opposite
acceptance right because
what jamie is really struggling with
here with the comparison is a lack of
acceptance because you can see that jeep
and say wow what a beautiful jeep
and accept the fact that you don't own
it right and say and then you can
actually appreciate it for what it is
but as soon as i need to acquire it or
change myself
now it is a type of prison because as
soon as i get that that object of my
desire almost immediately becomes the
object of my discontent now i have the
monthly car payment now i have to pay
for insurance now i have to worry about
it getting scratched or dinged up now i
have to worry about it getting stolen
like david or danny over here and so now
i'm constantly worried about the thing
that i thought was supposed to bring me
all this joy it's doing the exact
opposite and then we start asking
ourselves why did i buy this in the
first place why did i even want this
stupid thing let me get rid of it and
then we start decluttering and we have
to be careful to not re-clutter and how
do you do that by accepting it i don't
need it
to be able to appreciate it
jamie i'd love to send you a copy of
our minimalist rule book because
part of acceptance is setting up some
boundaries for yourself you can download
it for free the minimalists.com
rulebook or if you want the audiobook
version you do have to pay for that one
but jamie won't make you pay for it
we'll send you a copy of that my
favorite audiobook that we've done ryan
is the minimalist rule book because we
read through the 16 different rules for
living with less and you and i just did
this commentary about each one and kind
of invented our own new rules it's a
it's a mix between audiobook and podcast
all together two and a half hours yeah
themlists.com rulebook if you want to
check that out did you enjoy this
standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel
100
advertisement free